if the internet founders who are
probably most of them still alive had
known history and studied with you how
should the internet social media have
been created differently in the 90s and
I remembered a lot of people who did
that we're studying what happened when
the printing press came on and we're
very excited about it a little bit
worried about it but not worried enough
what you're saying
I think if you if you look back on on
the way the printing press developed
there was a for-profit wing that
ultimately did finance itself by selling
ads and it evolved into newspapers and
magazines but that was only a fraction
of all the printed content that was out
there most printed content was
accessible free through things called
libraries and libraries were nonprofit
already existed they'd already exist the
public libraries gradually began to
spread in the Protestant realms because
remember process and ism insisted on
literacy country like mine Scotland went
from very low literacy to very high
literacy because of the Reformation
schools had libraries books were
regarded as a public good and this meant
that most printed content was not
provided by profit-making institutions
it was essentially free and crucially
catalogued in increasingly effective and
I'll call them objective ways anybody
who spent time in one of the great
libraries of the world say the Cambridge
University Library knows that the books
are sorted in such a way that you find
the book that you're after and next to
it a books on similar topics this is an
incredibly valuable thing if you're
doing serious research Google is not
like that you may think Google is like
that but you're wrong because that is
not how search works so I think when we
look back on the evolution of the
Internet the fatal mistake was to have
too much for profit and not enough we'll
call it Wikipedia not enough that was
nonprofit under the printing press by
maintaining a very large nonprofit
sector the network remained
distributed and that was probably the
original sin of the internet to allow
the sale of ads to be the driver of
revenue for increasingly powerful
corporations I'll say one more thing cuz
it's a great question if you look back
on the events that led from the
foundation of Amazon to the dominance of
the network platforms in our time it was
a kind of slow burn it was only really
in the last ten years that the monopoly
capitalism aspect became apparent so I
don't think one can be too harsh on the
people who designed the Internet and the
world wide web they thought it would
stay distributed I think that was Tim
berners-lee's vision the printing press
had stayed distributed even the most
powerful newspaper barons like William
Randolph Hearst did not get anywhere
close to the market shares of Facebook
and Google today it's very surprising
that we got to this place and I don't
think we can blame ourselves for not
predicting it
you